[Música]
qué sabemos de los cristianos en medio
oriente oriente es el origen del
cristianismo son ciriaco greco ortodoxos
greco católicos coptos o incluso
maronitas y constituyen un mosaico
confesional rico en sus ritos y sus
lenguas los cristianos de esta región
tienen 2000 años de historia entre la
emancipación y la persecución su
experiencia a testigos a los múltiples
acontecimientos que sacudieron la región
ahora viven en una región de mayoría
musulmana pero su situación varía según
sean iraquíes sirios libaneses
palestinos o egipcios aunque su
situación en líbano es más sólida que en
el resto de la región les preocupan las
presiones internas y regionales para el
cristianismo palestina es un importante
lugar de peregrinación pero que
permanece bajo las limitaciones de la
ocupación israelí en egipto casi uno de
cada diez habitantes es cristiano de una
población de 100 millones son
esencialmente coptos los ataques contra
ellos han creado un sentimiento de
inseguridad el peligro es mayor en irak
y siria antes de la intervención
estadounidense en irak en 2003 había 15
millones desde entonces su número se ha
reducido a 150.000 una disminución del
90% en siria la población cristiana se
estima en 500.000 contra 1,5 millones
antes de la guerra civil de 2011 los
abusos cometidos por el grupo estado
islámico han llevado a los cristianos al
éxodo
qué hay de hoy todavía hay esperanza de
que los cristianos regresen a sus
tierras en la región iraquí de nínive
más de la mitad de las familias
cristianas han regresado a sus aldeas en
síria la reconstrucción está en marcha
[Música]